so in Islam we have these creations
aside from human beings called Jinn and
they're very similar to you know you
guys call them demons right it's the
same thing and there's one thing
particularly that I wanted to kind of
ask you guys but in Christianity Satan
is a fallen angel correct yes in Islam
the Quran through you know the Quran
Allah tells us that shaytan or you know
Iblis who Satan is not a fallen angel
It's a Jinn and this is kind of cool
because when I found that out I always
wondered why in Christianity they you
know you guys believe that it's a fallen
angel because wouldn't God create an
angel who has kind of you know for the
purpose of just obeying God's
Commandments and being kind of just
solely instructed for that one thing so
when I found out that oh how could
something that God created fall off
course like that when it was solely
created without Free Will without any
you know I guess capability of
comprehension or thought or free will
how could that happen and then when I
found out that in Islam we believe that
you know Satan is a Jinn to me that was
kind of different and I guess it just
appealed a little bit more to me but I
want to know your thoughts on that so I
he was a an archangel which is you know
like a top level uh Executive Vice
President Angel and I do believe they
had free will but you know I have to now
I have to verify that so that that I
think is why he was able to fall or the
others did not but it's it's a good
question and now I want to know yeah
because in this land the Angels don't
have free will and if you actually this
is where I'm kind of like now curious
you you said that it's supposed to be
from your research there's um
there's certain things within the Bible
that have not changed okay and where
this thing that we're saying now about
Satan you know when he's being referred
to as a an angel an archangel like where
exactly in the Bible was this right if
it's in a place where it was altered
well then how how much can you actually
believe what was being said and if you
if if we see the angels as as having no
free will but then we see the Gin Gin or
another creation kind of like us they
also have free will they also live like
us they also eat like us they also have
families like us they have the choice
whether they want to do good whether
they want to do bad whether they want to
worship God whether they don't want to
worship so it's like in the Quran Satan
was this Jinn that was like
basically the top of the top like how
you said this Archangel is the top of
the top well he was his gin that was the
top of the top that so much so that he
was actually brought close to God and
when God was creating Adam first he he
first he made the body he made the body
as if like imagine this like empty
vessel this like empty clay thing or
this empty like I don't know just like a
statue or something like this right he
made the Statue and he's basically
saying like this is this is my creation
and then he's telling all the angels
prostrate and at least Satan didn't
prostrate he didn't prostate because he
was looking at this he was like knocking
on it going in going out of it and he's
like I'm not going to prostrate to this
because I'm better than this like you
made me of a smokeless fire yet here you
made this creation of of dirt like I'm
not going to I'm not going to prosper to
that and from there that's that's
everything that's what caused his fall
and you see it on the Bible too the
arrogance that caused him to fall so
then he came back and he like said eat
the apple and he was like I'm gonna run
this guy
right or something like that uh I'm
gonna I'm just gonna look up like did
archangels have free will because I I
really I may not find the answer quickly
this may be deeper than than all that
but yeah so I I think generally and
obviously there's different
denominations I think generally
Christians think that uh he did have a
quarter according to the according to
Google page one he had for Lucifer had
Free Will okay we'll go deeper later
sorry go ahead mommy yeah no worries
noise yeah that's that's what Christians
believe and and it's usually basically
it helps justify the idea that Satan was
a fallen angel because it's just a
difference of belief Christians believe
angels have free will Muslims don't it's
just a different theology it's not
something too too important just
different viewpoints
um but yeah long story short basically
Satan afterwards he he swore he made
basically I promise that I'm going to
try my best to misguide everyone and
Allah said listen you won't misguide
anyone except those who like basically
are they don't mind being astray no they
don't actually want the truth they don't
want to be guided but my servants the
ones that obey me basically try go try
see what happens and alhamdulillah you
know we're still very very strong yeah
and uh some of us are Untouchable not
speaking of myself but some people are
just you know there's actually a Hadith
narration of of one of the companions of
the Prophet The Prophet peace upon him
he said when he sees this when Satan
sees this companion walking he basically
walks the other way he doesn't even try
with them that's you know hopefully the
the level we hope to get to all right
make sure you guys like subscribe and if
you're interested in learning how to
dominate social media and make money
online I'm having a crazy sale with my
Online Academy where I teach you all my
strategies how I've hit over a hundred
thousand Subs in four months how I've
generated five million dollars using
organic marketing so DM me bank if you
guys want to learn more about that
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings
[Music]